bonjour je suis le seul en chef romain
je suis du 3e régiment d'infanterie de
marine
je suis sniper ou tireur d'élite
[Musique]
on peut neutraliser une cible personnel
jusqu'à une distance de 1500 m et cible
véhicules légers jusqu'à une distance de
1800 mètres
[Musique]
la plus petite entité tireurs d'élite
celle au trinôme donc le chef d'equipe
autonome le spotter et le tireur le
spotter ou chef de pièce lui son rôle
est de calculer prendre les données
climatiques pour calculer les
corrections effectuées sur larmes et
pouvoir les retransmettre à son tireur
donc c'est le spotter qui guide le tir
le spotter est très important c'est à
peu près 70 % du tir en lui-même
le reste est effectuée par tirage
[Musique]
le rôle de tireur d'élite au sein d'un
conflit c'est de pouvoir détacher
d'une compagnie pour effectuer des
missions autonome le tireur d'élite à la
faculté de se déplacer très discrètement
ses objectifs ses deux d'effectuer des
tirs sur cibles prioritaires et de
d'effectuer du renseignement et
d'observation en vue de renseigner les
chevaux supérieur